on the mound for the home side it's
pablo lopez a 25 year old right hander
who is in his third season with the
marlins six and four last year 3.61 era
which would have been a lot lower had it
not been for
two of his 11 starts that went south in
a hurry one coming against these very
same tampa bay rays so two goals lead
things off for the defending american
league champs tatugo sends the ball the
other way well hit adam duvall is out
there one of the new marlins and there's
one guy yesterday's race hero austin
meadows here's the next three two we
went back out there with the change up
and lost meadows there's randy arose
arena now one for four in the opener
yesterday all eyes will be on a rose
arena this season in tampa that's for
sure
shoots that one through the hole on the
right side to base it
and the rays have something cooking
early with one out to start the ball
game
so an early opportunity here for tampa
bay for the rays team mvp last year
second baseman brandon lau a ball and
two strikes to loud
and it's the first strike out of the
ball game for pablo lopez
so two gone now for yandi diaz trying to
cash in on an early opportunity little
topper back to the mound for lopez and
he'll strand a pair
in his lid lifter of 2021.
it's ryan yarbrough on the mound for the
tampa bay rays
as he goes to work on miguel rojas
yarbrough coming off a very good
2020 a career low 3.56 era massed over
11 appearances nine of them starts two
balls and two strikes to rojas who is
not one of those guys and there's a
little flare out that tottugo won away
one gun now for starling marte yarbros
102 him is swung on and sent out to left
that's where austin meadows will gather
in the routine chance to gone
here's jesus aguilar two balls and two
strikes once again to aguilar swings
through at that time scoreless start to
the ball game through and inning if
you're a marlin you'd like to get that
first run pushed across the board sooner
rather than later that is an alarming
stat the marlins have gone down in order
in seven of their first 10 innings this
year again tip your cap to the raise
outstanding pitching staff but here's
garrett cooper
cooper's run up here's brian anderson
now hitless to start the season with
yesterday's 0-3
[Music]
he picks on the first pitch and pops it
into foul territory for tsutugo here's
adam duvall now with two gone five in a
row set down by yarbrough to start the
ball game the ball lifts the fly ball
harmlessly out to left
another chance for meadows and six up
six down for ryan yarbrough to begin the
night scoreless in miami as yoshi
tsutsugo leads things off against pablo
lopez as tattoo goes straightened up on
the fastball that time that's the very
stuff that gave him trouble last year to
randy arose arena who's singled in his
first try tonight
lopez gets him for his third strike out
of the night
and efficient one two three third and
yar broke back in it and back to work in
the third he gets jazz chisholm got a
big swing too this one's not going to
have enough that's that's
something easy pop now the marlins over
12 leading off and ending this season
again it's a team that doesn't have an
extra base hit yet this year
on the ground for the shortstop wendell
and a quick second out pablo lopez
throws right and as you can see bats
left same kind of play
broken back
and wendell gathers in to make for a
very quick one two three third ryan
yarbrough perfect through the first
three innings tonight ryan yarbrough
back to work a scoreless ball game last
half of the fourth and the top of the
order here for the marlins who've been
set down in order in each of their first
three innings to begin the ball game
knocked it down got to it and throws to
first not in time rojas beats it out
here's my first argument hey it's the
tie does not go to the runner you have
to beat it that means you have to be
there before he catches it if you're
there the same time you're out there's a
little tidbit for you it's a good one
first base runner of the ball game for
the marlins and here's starling marty
now
marte shoots a ball back up the middle
back to back singles open the fourth
so for the first time tonight tampa bay
left-hander and tampa bay fan brian
yarbrough is in a little bit of trouble
here's jesus aguilar now aguilar
fly ball out to center in right center
field is where emanuel margot makes a
kelly league style play
and there's one gone finally the marlins
looking to scratch across their first
run of 2021 and cooper was a good hitter
last year with runners on base
line to third and the rays turn it into
a double play
just like that houdini yarbrough is out
of a mess pablo lopez has struck out
three tonight francisco mejia now and
there's a front base hit please i gotta
leave for a little while but that's
special
oh man
that took you to a blissful place dude
oh special here's ryan yarbrough now
you're surprised i'm not butting her yes
you got a guy trying to put the ball in
play you got a double play weight now
that's absolutely right
line to second base and that'll turn
into a double play exactly the scenario
you were talking about trying to avoid
wow it has taken a couple of funky
moments to keep this game scoreless as
brian anderson leads things off in the
fifth
smothered by diaz gets to his feet and
on one hop still has enough to throw out
anderson that was a little bit of a
circus act by yandi but he did make the
out happen well pablo lopez was terrific
tonight five shout out innings but he is
lifted here after five in in
place of richard bleyer one gun now for
austin meadows whose homer yesterday
has still accounted for the only run of
this series meadows does it again
on an owen two pitch
one nothing tempo
his second homer in seven plate
appearances this season ryan yarbrough
who gets a run thanks to the austin
meadows homer last half-inning
one-nothing tampo
and that's inside the line into the
corner and left marte around first on
his way in a second with the marlins
first extra base hit of the year that'll
be all for yabro exiting with two out in
a runner at second in a one-nothing lead
two games in two outings for second year
raised right-hander pete fairbanks and
now there's runners in first and second
with two gun for garrett cooper here we
go another big opportunity for him here
and a breaking ball served into right
a rosarena retires the side and
fairbanks gets out of another jam
emanuel margot now with two gods kevin
cash gave us fair warning keep an eye on
manny margot he had the best spring of
anyone in camp a drive to left and that
one's well struck it takes duvall back
to the wall and it's gone
emanuel margot has made it to nothing
tampa bay
i think he just called that chance row
is the new tampa pitcher working here in
the seventh unless you're jesus aguilar
or starling marty you're now three for
40 as a team and here's chisholm now
chisholm sends a ball out to right and
that'll bounce off the wall
he's on his way into third with zugan
the throw is off line
well this guy is fun to watch
yeah and the blue do man i'm sold on it
both managers exercising some bench
depth and it'll be corey dickerson to
bet off the bench for miami as chas row
is replaced by the left-hander ryan
sherrod tying runs on base chugon last
to the seventh a two-nothing tampa bay
lead the sheriff is trying to hold into
the opposite corner
and that'll drive in miami's first run
of the season
it's a two to one ball game i think this
is an example of the three rule normally
this guy wouldn't be facing the top door
with all the right-hand hitters yep
it'll flip the lineup card back to
miguel rojas
sharply hit through the hole and this
one is at least tied alfaro scores
throw on dickerson's not in time and the
marlins have taken their first lead of
the year four consecutive marlins with
two gone have all reached base
it's translated into three runs in
miami's first league anthony bass has a
new contract he is the ninth inning man
for the marlins and gets a save
opportunity his first of the year
tonight
lot thickens in the ninth first and
second with one gun it's a big outing
for bass you know he's trying to
establish himself so here's joey wendell
now
tying runs on base
the 1-2 pitch
and wendell sends a ball to right that
one's going to go snatch them back
three run homer and tampa bay goes back
out on top wow diego castillo will try
to close things down here in the ninth
it's going to be magnarius sierra and he
represents the tying run with two out in
the last of the night this will be the
fifth time in the last seven years
they've opened a season oh and two
and that is exactly their fate
as tampa bay puts the finishing touches
on an exciting 6-4 come from behind
victory